[Music]
and wonderful
until it's not I'm not happy what tell
me what's wrong I don't know and this is
the person that I met three years ago
that guy was romantic romantic you're
pissing in front of me
yeah I'm staying hydrated you should be
happy for me I'm a vegetarian I'll bait
fish and pepperoni on pizza cuz that
doesn't count
[Music]
mr. Huffington attorney a dog he's a
lawyer
Wow
[ __ ] me oh yeah we tell anyone if he
happy games are your father dead I
didn't say that I heard you I didn't
mean it
this is so hard doesn't it have to be
well just won't be happy no it's not
called gently refining it love it still
following another because yeah it could
hurt place you're never gonna know
unless you jump off the ledge sure you
are so worried about everybody else that
you don't give a [ __ ] about the one
person that's most matter most well
that's so nice Sam but was the last time
a cabbie gave you a blow job does an
uber driver count that's not funny I'm
not laughing it is kind of funny well so
just gonna lay here and let him go
stop punishing yourself on something
simpler many Molly and I are just too
different like I see the glass of water
is half-full she sees the water as
poison
ever seen how much pressure there is for
me is easy for you I don't want to have
a baby when I'm old man who can't pick
up his [ __ ] - I could think of
nothing you would love more than not
having to carry your baby yeah that
would be nice
[Music]
you